وستكون هذه حكومه بنيامين نتنياهو سادسه
وتستند لقاعده برلمانيه تلافيه من 64
نائبا في الكنيسه ال 25
حسبالي كود بيزعامه ميزانيه وحصل على 32
مقعدا في الانتخابات الاخيره سيتولى رئاسه
الوزراء الى جانب حقائب وزاريه مهمه مثل
الخارجيه والدفاع اما تحالف الصهيونيه
الدينيه زعامه
بتسلي». اكبر حزب في الكنيسه ويطالب
بحقائب الماليه او الدفاع والامن الداخليه
لما حصلت حركه لليهود المتدينين الشرقيه
او الداخليه اما حزب يهده هجرات لليهود
المتدينين الغربي
ويطالب بحقيبتي كان والصحه
من القدس مدير مكتب الجزيره وليد العمري
ينضم الينا وليد اهلا بك لعل السؤال
الرئيسي الان هو حول توزيع اذا الحقائب ما
اهم اذا السيناريوهات بشان هذه الحكومه
الاسرائيليه المقبله وهل سيكون هناك اي
نوع من التسويه ربما مع المعارضه
لا يبدو انه ستكون هناك اي تسويه مع
المعارضه لان كافه قاده المعارضه الذين هم
الائتلاف المنصرف حاليا كانوا قد اعلنوا
انهم لن يشاركوا في حكومه برئاسه نتنياهو
لكن السياسه تتبدل وتتغير وقد تختلف
المصالح مثل ما جرى في مرات سابقه وقد
يجدونها جانسي همم من المعسكر الرسمي ينضم
ثانيه الى نتنياه بذريعه انقاذ اسرائيل من
التطرف لكن السيناريو الاقوى حاليا هو ان
نتنياهو سيقيموا تحالفا او ائتلافا حكوميا
مفرطا في تطرفه يضم اللكود برئاسته وتحالف
الفاسيين من الصهيونيه الدينيه بزعامه
موتريت
والحزبان والحزبين المتدينين المتزامتين
الحديدين شاس الشرقيه
ويهدودها التراب الغربيين لكن الخلاف يدور
بالفعل وهذه العقده التي جعلت له يرجئ عرض
حكومته المقبله وهي السادسه على الكنيسه
غداه اداء الكنيست القسم يوم الثلاثاء همم
الى الاسبوع الذي يليه هو ان هناك خلاف
واسرار سيموتريتش وبنجبير وسباني على
انهما يجب ان يحصل على الحقائب التاليه
اما الماليه والدفاع او الامن الداخلي هذا
ما يبحث عن يعني حقيبتان من هذه الحقائب
السياديه وهناك معارضه شديده في المجتمع
الاسرائيلي لذلك وهناك ايضا داخل اللكود
حاله من الانزعاج الذين يخشون من ان يوافق
نتنياهو في النهايه ويمنحهم حقيبتين من
هذه الحقائب الثلاث وهناك حركه التي ابلغ
زعيمها درع نتنياه برغبته الحصول على
حقيبه الماليه لكن واضح بانها ستقبل في
نهايه المطاف بحقيبه الداخليه وحقائب اخرى
اقل اهميه واما ال- حدودها التراث
اليهود الغربيه فصلحتها واضحه هذه غير
الصهيونيه لكنها تشارك في الحكومه برتبه
نائب وزير وتصر على الحصول على حقيبه
الاسكان وكذلك على حقيبه اخرى ربما
الاديان برتبه نائب وزير الاهم ان هذه
الاحزاب المتدينه الثلاث تريد ايضا مضاعفه
مخصصات
تلاميذ المدارس الدينيه من يسمونهم
بتلاميذ التوراه وهذا يزعج الاسرائيلي
الذين يقولون بان من لا يخدم في الجيش
يحصل على مخصصات المضاعفه عاما يخدم في
الجيش هذه المعادله التي يعكس عليها حاليا
وكان قد وعد جميع حلفائه بذلك لكن واضح
انه بدونهم لا يستطيع ان يقيم حكومه وهم
بدونه لن يكون جزءا من الحكومه فعلى
الاغلب ان يتوافقوا في نهايه المطاف على
التسويه شكرا جزيلا لك وليد العمري مدير
مكتب الجزيره من القدس